pour revenir sur cet acte 63 nous sommes
avec faouzi lellouche l'une des figures
du mouvement des gilets jaunes faouzi
lellouche bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on a
entendu un seul ce gilet jaune à
l'instant qui disait si il faut marcher
300 actes je le ferais s'il faut marcher
jusqu'à 80 ans je le ferais ça sert à
quoi
aujourd'hui encore de marché 63e semaine
on le disait selon vous déjà j'aimerais
féliciter et remercier tous ces gens qui
se sont mobilisés on peut dire qu'ils se
sont impliqués pour essayer de penser à
l'ensemble de des gens qui vivent dans
notre société pour essayer d'améliorer
l'ordinaire et essayer de de dénoncer
les injustices qui peut y avoir dans ce
pays
les injustices sociales fiscales et
environnementales et les injustices tout
court parce qu'on a pu voir tout ce qui
s'est passé au niveau de la justice et
la disproportion selon que vous êtes un
citoyen ou un représentant ou un élu et
donc ces gens par leur implication sont
engagés dans quelque chose qui qui est
vraiment valorisant qu'ils aient quelque
chose à mon goût qui n'a jamais qui n'a
pas de précédent
je pense que la sincérité de
l'engagement il est réel il est visible
malgré la répression malgré ce que le
gouvernement essayait de faire depuis
des mois et a essayé de dissuader allait
aussi exerçant une répression une
répression d'état
en utilisant la police pour pour faire
tout ce qu'elle a à faire en condamnant
des gens les blessant et franchement je
sais des gens qui sont déterminés parce
que c'est plus profond que ce qu'on peut
défendre c'est un idéal de vie c'est
c'est une doctrine c'est des valeurs
c'est la base de notre société voilà
pourquoi il est prêt à le faire jusqu'à
ses 80 ans mais honnêtement ils ont un
grand mérite parce que c'est pas facile
justement phoneeasy lellouche y parlait
des mensonges
est-ce que c'est pas aussi avec tous les
les personnes que vous rencontrez chaque
samedi
c'est pas aussi une volonté de vérité
une quête de vérité au fond ce mouvement
c'est ce que révèle ce mouvement en tout
cas depuis le début il s'avère que ces
gens sont sincères et souhaite en face
d'eux avoir des gens qui les
représentent
mais avec une éthique avec avec une
déontologie avec une façon de le faire
mais qui qu'ils soient sincères qu'ils
soient honnêtes et beaucoup de
gouvernements successifs dont celui là
l'on peut dire c'est le pire au niveau
de la répression et de la considération
qui peut y avoir sur les citoyens ne
sont pas ne sont pas exemplaires par
leurs agissements mais surtout par
toutes les affaires qu'on a pu voir
depuis des années et aujourd'hui les
gens et réclame quoi de la considération
pouvoir vivre décemment mieux être
respectée mais surtout avoir des gens
qui sont au gouvernement et qu'il soit
de tout exemplarité qu'ils soient pas
des tricheurs des ventes des voleurs des
menteurs des et le problème c'est que
quel choix on a on a nous on a voté
comme on vote depuis tous les cinq ans
des gens sont à la tête après n'écoute
plus les citoyens et font ce qu'ils ont
envie eux pour leurs propres intérêts
alors que normalement on pourrait on
pourrait presque les accusés de trahison
ils sont en train de vendre le
patrimoine français ils sont pas en
train de prendre en compte la volonté
des citoyens et son île je sais pas il
écoute personnes et
ils entendent mais ils font ils prennent
des décisions qui sont celles qui les
arrangent eux du coup au détriment de
l'intérêt général
en tout cas ça fait des semaines et des
semaines que vous dénoncer les violences
policières la répression vous venez de
le dire une nouvelle voie on les a vu
toutes ces images entre aujourd'hui en
tout cas pour le moment et la
manifestation d'hier ce qui a marqué
c'était le calme à de contact en tout
cas pas de face-à-face
est-ce que selon vous et bien vous avez
pu être entendue et les consignes
données aux forces de l'ordre ont évolué
et est ce que c'est quelque chose que
vous avez pu constater non du tout pour
moi c'est pas c'est pas du fait des
forces de l'ordre c'est du fait
simplement des manifestants et on a pu
voir une disproportion des forces de
l'ordre du dispositif aussi bien hier
dans la manifestation parce que je suis
allé jusqu'à concorde et j'ai pu voir
franchement un dispositif démesurée avec
bien sûr derrière des grillages des
équipes qui nous attendait sur place
enfin elle prête à tout quoi et
honnêtement aujourd'hui je suis pas
rentré dans la manifestation
on était deux on a suivi la
manifestation pour voir un petit peu le
comportement le dispositif tel qu'il
était mis en place mais c'est ahurissant
incroyable toutes ces forces de l'orde
aussi bien les gendarmes les policiers
les crs
mais c'est là on penserait que on est on
est en guerre ou qu'on est con et
dangereux quand j'arrive pas à
comprendre ce dispositif
et je peux vous dire que malgré tout ce
qui s'est passé depuis
depuis 14 mois où on peut dénombrer
énormément de blessés mais je comprends
qu'il y ait des gens qui aient peur qui
est des craintes à venir marcher dans la
rue pour dénoncer toute cette injustice
alors un moment qu'est ce qui nous reste
moi je pense honnêtement que de marcher
comme ça au risque est d'être exposé
déjà ça nécessite et ça mérite
énormément de de courage de ce qu'ils le
font mais surtout est ce qu'on va
pouvoir continuer comme ça à s'exposer à
voir des gens qui sont blessés
qui sont arrêtés pour rien du tout on a
pu voir il ya quinze jours
soixante personnes interpellées on est
allé au tribunal de grande instance à
clichy où on en était là pour les gens
qui a été mis en comparution immédiate
mais avec des condamnations des reports
d'audiences messi mais c'est la folie on
a le sentiment qu'il ya une
disproportion alors que nous on attend
toujours des résultats suite à l'igpn
toutes les plaintes qui ont été posées
on voit que la justice allait pas il n'y
a pas de justice dans ce pays
en tout cas les pas ll n'est pas égal
elle n'est pas le traitement n'est pas
n'est pas équitable pour tout le monde
et en l'occurrence et les citoyens qu'il
le paye parce que on n'appartient pas ou
une organisation ou un corps d'état ou
voilà on voit la différence juste en
deux mots pour conclure on est à deux
mois des élections municipales quel est
le mot d'ordre du mouvement des gilet
jaune a alors là c'est ses ouailles on a
dit les gens qui veulent aller aux
municipales qu'ils y aillent parce qu'on
pense que un élu d'une commune à maire
d'une commune
ça se rapproche plus du social c'est la
proximité avec les habitants
avec notre quotidien maintenant on
dénonce un système c'est compliqué pour
moi par exemple ne serait-ce que moi
dans ma ville d'essayer d'espérer
candidater pour être mère parce que je
dénonce ce système si je deviens maire
ou jeu candidate
ça veut dire je veux rentrer dans ce
système je pense qu'il faut le dénoncer
avant de pouvoir y accéder à mon avis
merci beaucoup faouzi lellouche d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes l'une des figures du mouvement
du gilet jaune